that's my thimble collection I do love
it so
hi i'm fred armisen and these are some
youtube videos that I really enjoy
meaning I even though I've seen them a
million times just like a record I will
go back and watch it again one of them
is a music video it's by one of my
favorite bands called Kraftwerk they're
this German band but for some reason
their music was so digital back in 1981
that it actually keeps aging really well
I'm the Opera top of my pocket not your
late mom some of it looks like it's live
and I've seen them perform that song
live and it's always great so Kraftwerk
with a k' pocket calculator I think I'll
just do two music ones because then if I
do too many it's like we get it you're a
music guy the second one is one of my
favorite bands ever they are called the
Damned
[Music]
they're in a very white room and they
sort of blew out the video so it just
looks overly white it makes me really
happy and it's called smash it up by the
Damned with addy
[Music]
sometimes and this is something you guys
can pick on your own because I sometimes
like to do subject matter watching a
parrot hearing them talk
it is fascinating I cannot believe the
things they say they sound so human the
beaks their mouths aren't even like our
mouths and still they mimic all these
sounds staying with the animal theme
Coco the gorilla is this gorilla that
does sign language and it's pretty great
there's one recently that they've posted
where she's watching a movie I'm a big
geek with partly going off and a sad
part came up there's a finale to the
movie and the kids waving goodbye to his
parents they go off on a train and Coco
the gorilla turns around and says in
sign language I can't watch this part
it's too sad already it's a Thai North
bed scene Oh when they're crying they
are crying it was really incredible I
don't know why this isn't front-page
news every single day why for some
reason it's just relegated to just like
something that likes some people know
about well I know it's hard to watch
that the last thing I'm going to do
there is what what I think is the best
sketch that has ever existed
for me in my taste and it's a mr. show
schedule Thomas oh yo did it climb Mount
Everest and he's like yes it was such a
great job let me tell you all about it
oh that's new oh that's nice symbol
collection I do love it so I set up this
little collection of symbols on the wall
a suddenly felt my quick broke go slap
oh but before I was able to all the
thimbles just like all over the floor
it's a horrible moment like it's okay
taking a Sun I'm just gonna set up the
Shelf again you can tell it's a story
the wind blew
this sketch keeps going or he keeps
trying to tell the story and he keeps
bringing down these thimbles again you
know it's coming he's going to do it
again
I rested upon what I thought was this
something about it really makes me laugh
every time thanks for watching even if
you watched only a little bit of it
that's okay don't feel bad if you like
only watch like half of something
because that's what we need to get over
is that guilt they'll always be there
and you can always go back and visit
them like an old friend